there are a lot of people in the united
states purely based on the data who are
experiencing sub clinical
uh insufficiencies related to either
circulating levels of micronutrients or
actual intakes of nutrients and those
can very easily be rectified with uh
with supplementation strategies that are
very
cost effective have an extremely good
safety profile and do have the potential
for some benefit uh another
thing i often see when people push back
against this is they'll be like dude
vitamins are useless and they'll send me
a study and it'll be like a big
randomized controlled trial and they'll
say like
people with uh people taking
multivitamins didn't live longer i'm
like yeah i didn't think you were gonna
die yeah from from not taking a
multivitamin it's a matter of
like are you hitting these these
benchmarks for adequate intake and if
not might you have a better subjective
experience day to day and be in a
generally healthier place if you were
hitting those benchmarks for adequate
intake yeah i i've seen that as well
with uh with vitamin d like a couple
people have hit me up on instagram uh
saying like hey eric has talked about uh
vitamin d supplementation on the podcast
before
new study just came out turns out that
supplementing with vitamin d doesn't
improve strength hypertrophy outcomes
i'm like
that's really cool but did you know that
vitamin d interacts with more things in
your body than your musculoskeletal
system
that uh
may be relevant
yeah so um so yeah that that's really
just the
the the root of any disagreement like uh
you know sometimes and
it's important to recognize like if you
say i don't think i need a multivitamin
i don't think i need vitamin d i don't
think i need fish oil like
it's very unlikely that you're gonna
experience uh a clinically relevant
negative consequence of not taking any
of these supplements like i don't
consider them to be essential
but for people who are not being mindful
of their intakes of these nutrients and
are not getting sun exposure i do
recommend in many cases very
conservative supplementation
approaches which might be as simple as a
multivitamin and just enough fish oil to
get you close to what
what experts say is
an advisable intake of fish oil so i
don't think you're going to really make
or break your health or your performance
or your training adaptations by using
any of these categories of supplements
but i do view them as supplements that
aside from some very specific instances
generally have terrific safety profiles
and generally are quite affordable